[Music]
Mayakovsky I'm a product manager in
container security at Google hi I'm
Jesse I'm the chief product officer and
chief security officer at a startup
called fleet Smith you have a lot of
titles Jesse feel free to tweet at us
later or during the talk so we'll be
talking first about what container
security is so why containers and why
kubernetes well criminales makes a lot
of constructs a little bit easier for
you to manage things like scheduling so
to decide where your containers get
deployed lifecycle management you know
how many containers you should have up
and running scaling to bring ups and
size downs sets of containers and load
balancing so you can set traffic to the
right sets of containers but kubernetes
also has a bunch of security features
built in things like logging and
monitoring to make it easier for you to
figure out what's happening in your
container this is not like a log
aggregation on mas but it gives you a
lot more than you would get otherwise
debugging and introspection to figure
out what's happening inside your
containers or to attach to your
containers and identity an authorization
to determine what who can do what with
your containers and more and more of
these things are being added to
communities as part of every release so
you're writing a lot of security
features built in running containers
though as a concept is a slightly
different security model than you're
used to it gives you a fundamentally
different set of benefits so containers
are short-lived and frequently
redeployed that means you can be
constantly patching your environment
things that you were doing passively
before like patching your OS where you
have to take down you know Sunday 2:00
a.m. maintenance windows you don't have
to do anymore
you can just patch that image and then
redeploy it passively when new container
comes up in your environment containers
are also immutable so you can you can
control what's deployed in your
environment by having these short-lived
containers you have a single enforcement
point a single choke point for
everything that ends up in your
environment it's much easier to figure
out for example if you're subject to a
particular vulnerability because you
know what you've deployed a common
reason people don't want to use
containers for security is isolation you
know they say hey I have this thing
called a hypervisor that I'm that I know
really well with a virtual machine and I
know it's really secure and isolates my
workload and until recently until things
like gee visor we didn't have something
similar with containers so now we do and
that's actually one of the greatest
strengths to use in containers from a
security point of view and lastly a lot
good security defaults in containers and
communities are one line changes you can
follow best practices like enabling set
comp without taking on a lot of the work
yourself so it's it's really containers
allow you to think completely
differently about how you can match
patch and manage your system compared to
how you're doing with virtual machines
so your mind that's a little bit
different but a lot of a lot of things
are the same right if you had an
identity management solution system with
your VMs you have an identity management
system with your containers if you had a
network management system a network
security solution you have a network
security solution here you still want
firewalls right you still want an IDs
IPS etc that stuff doesn't change so
what does actually change a few things
which will point out here the first is
the surface of attack so your container
doesn't have this hypervisor but it does
have this host OS that you're running
around with you're running your
containers on and the container itself
has its own OS bundled with libraries
and dependencies that host OS is
supposed to be really small it's
supposed to be something that you can
run everywhere that you it's really easy
for you to patch and manage so if you're
doing containers properly you're
thinking about securing that host OS
really tightly and patching it and
keeping it minimal resource isolation
containers have concepts for resource
isolation built-in like namespaces and C
groups so you can use those natively to
do to do that without having to bring in
other other capabilities permission
management so access controls for a
privileges and shared resources are
built into containers but keep in mind
that containers have access to a wider
range of syscalls
then a traditional process would so it
potentially is much more powerful in the
last eight lifetime containers have a
shorter average of life lifetime in fact
Cystic estimates that 95% of containers
live less than a week what that means is
that you you know an attacker who gets
into your environment
she can't persist there as long much
longer than a week it's much harder for
someone to stay there without you
knowing that being said by the time you
figure out something bad has gone on the
attacker might not be there anymore the
container might not be there anymore you
might not be able to do forensics and
figure out what happened in your
environment so this brings us a little
bit to however you think about container
security at Google some of the different
kinds of threats that we see so things
like the first are the talk to attacks
to crannies peripherals things like
credential theft privilege escalation
the API compromise etc
these are things around how you
configure communities configure
environment the next one are software
supplied software supply chain
vulnerability unpatched vulnerability is
a new O'Day that drops in a common
library an issue with open source
library that you're using etc and lastly
we have things that really scare people
things like DDoS attacks container
escapes flooding your event pipeline
compromising the nodes that you're
running on etc and so we've grouped
these into three different areas
infrastructure security software supply
chain and container runtime security
infrastructure security is about how you
secure the development of your
containers how do i do secret management
networking access management I am all of
those things to make sure that the
environment that I'm developing that
kubernetes or communities engine is
secure software supply chain is about
making sure that the images that I
deploy and the binaries that I use are
secure for building and deploying in my
environment how do I know that there are
free vulnerabilities how do I know that
they came out of my build pipeline etc
in container run time security is making
sure that my container is secure to run
its my traditional psych ops team you
know the people in the sock who are
gonna set have to sit there and respond
to an incident what can they get how do
they know what's happening in my
container how do they do forensics after
the fact and make sure that that we've
gotten rid of that that threat
so the question you're probably asking
yourselves and a lot of people ask
themselves and sometimes I ask myself
when I wake up is like how do I secure
kubernetes it's this like massive thing
that nobody really understands yet and
that's right lots of people don't
understand it it's so new that a lot of
people don't know what the security
controls that come with carbonates are
so that's we're really trying to just
today teach you about some of the things
that existing for bananas and
incriminates engine to help secure your
environment so it's really important to
remember that kubernetes is only the
sort of middle slice in a greater
picture and so you don't want to forget
about securing your application layer
your containers whatever your container
runtime is maybe that stalker
your virtual machines they're actually
running sort of below but today we're
obviously talking about the middle layer
of kubernetes itself yeah what are some
of the components that we have yeah so
there's really only three major kind of
pieces first you've got the sort of
storage layer you
think of that like kubernetes hard drive
that's where all of your cluster State
is gonna live next up you've got your
master that's what's actually
controlling your entire cluster next of
course you have the nodes that's
basically going to be virtual machines
and that's where your workloads are
actually deployed so that's where your
pods are deployed and pods are really
just collections of containers so now we
can go ahead and walk through some of
the different things that could kind of
go wrong at each of these layers so
starting from the top down if an
attacker controls a container what's the
worst case scenario the worst case
scenario is that they escape and they're
able to attack the node right if they
attack the node they can also control
all the pods running on that node and
then potentially attack the next layer
up the master or they could abuse
compute maybe to you know mine
cryptocurrency for example affect the
other workloads that you have running so
that you know it's something else that's
really critical might not be able to run
as you wanted it to and then of course
if they can control the storage layer at
CD that means they can create you know
modify or destroy any state in your
cluster very similar to if someone
yanked out a hard drive from a computer
it's not encrypted they can just modify
whatever data they want to you so
obviously that's pretty bad as well yeah
this is a super helpful slide take a
photo this is the kind of thing that I
you know when I first started looking
into community security who didn't
didn't exist it was hard to explain and
to people why you had to protect that CD
or why you had to protect the master so
I often see people say hey I'll put you
know one key in that CD and I'll put one
key on the pod and it'll all be safe and
it's like what's your lowest common
denominator and it's getting to
something like a CD is pretty bad so
make sure something STDs pretty lock
down absolutely sure let's jump into
security requirements so typically when
we're having these kind of criminal
security 101 conversations there's two
different attacks that come along one is
a set of users who just want to have
basic security hygiene make sure that
they're not doing anything fundamentally
wrong they might have some compliance
requirements that they're trying to meet
they you know if you're just worried
about this kind of stuff making sure
you're not doing anything particularly
unusual then this talk is for you this
is
the basics in that security domain the
second set of users are people who might
be running a product in a more high-risk
industry and more more subject more
likely to be subject to attack that
doesn't mean of course that they don't
also have compliance regulations it just
may be it's not the same the same way of
thinking about it and for them this is a
good starting point
but we'll put a link at the end of the
talk that leads you to more and more
hardening advice so how do we know
anything about this topic I used to be
management consultant doing work with
financial healthcare and insurance
companies in security and Jessie here
leads Pete Smith tell us about that yeah
so because of what our product does we
have a really kind of high bar for
security and what our product does is it
automates Apple device setup including
the OS updates you know app
installations security settings things
related to compliance and so concretely
what that means is buy a laptop from
Apple drop ship it to an employee it
boots up and it configures itself
automatically so you know all the
important apps can install Google Chrome
Dropbox slack your VPN disk encryption
gets enforced all that stuff right but
obviously because of all that
functionality we have a need for a
strong security posture so that's one of
the reasons we chose Google cloud is
because of their approach to security
and then we also do some things on top
of that so we run our own kubernetes
deployment on top of GCE
and then we secure it with certs issued
from vault hasha core vault awesome
project I think there's a talk later on
yeah
and so all that's to say that's that's
where I'm coming from in terms of
background so I can your product lets me
use G suite authenticate and then you
guys run on G Sophie indeed like you
guys like love Google or something it's
great we do all right so let's talk
about the variety of things you might
want to do in your security journey to
getting to a secure Cabrini's deployment
there's a whole lot of things on this
slide talk us through some of these yeah
so obviously the first thing you need to
do especially a lot of these if you're
running your own cluster is sort of the
security of the cluster itself and so
that's things like restricting access to
Kubb cuddle group control
setting up and using our back for role
based access control using a network
policy setting up namespaces and of
course bootstrapping TLS which requires
that you have a CA to issue certs to
your entire kubernetes cluster next up
Senate following basic security hygiene
making sure you can use her containers
for that security benefit we were
talking about earlier
keeping kubernetes and your OS and your
images and your binaries everything
patched and updated using a minimal OS
like container optimized OS or costs on
gke using minimum iam rules to enforce
lease privilege using private IPS on
your nodes to make sure that nothing has
access from the public Internet that it
shouldn't monitoring access with audit
logging and then making sure that the
binaries that you deploy are those that
you build next up you're going to want
to prevent known attacks and so this is
going to be things like disabling the
built-in kubernetes dashboard if that's
running in your environment disabling
the default service account token that's
something that gets mounted
automatically into every new pod in your
cluster and it has some strong
permissions or privileges next is
protecting node metadata and finally
scanning images for known phones and at
the final step of your maturity security
journey here
preventing the impact of a potential
compromise so you know security is great
[ __ ] happens you know humans are make
errors what if something goes wrong you
want to have multiple layers of security
things like setting up odd security
policy to follow best practices like
seccomp protecting your secrets using
things like encryption considering using
sandboxing to protect workloads that
need to be isolated limiting the
identity that pods can use to
authenticate to other parts of your
infrastructure and using a service mesh
for authentication and encryption
between your services so obviously we
don't have time to talk about everything
on this list today and so what we've
optimized for is 6 things you can do
that are high impact and relatively low
sort of time investment that should
significantly increase your security
posture let's go through those six so
first up we have restricting access to
coop control I'm still good pedal
oh sorry using our back a role based
access control to define rules it's
basically kubernetes native identity and
access management next up is defining a
network policy and so by default all
pollak to pod traffic is open and so if
you don't like that and you want to
increase your security there you would
want to use a network policy protecting
the community's dashboard you might have
seen some high profile hacks recently if
I take advantage of this UI so you have
a couple options but the point is don't
leave it open next is disabling that
default service account token I
mentioned because if an attacker gets
access to it they could use it to do bad
things and then using positive carry
policy to follow best practices like set
comm for protecting your containers so
oh yes as we talk through this Jessi
will be talking about kubernetes since
he has all this experience deploying
communities on compute engine and I'll
be talking about kubernetes engine and
how we've deployed those things there a
couple something to keep in mind around
the shared responsibility model here is
that criminales engine takes care of the
master for you including at CD so you
have some options in terms of
configuration of certain features and
things like that but they're not your
responsibility they're Google's
responsibility to protect where as the
nodes containers and pods are still your
responsibility to protect the community
attention and maybe at the end of this
talk I'll have finally convinced you to
move over to communities engine alright
so number one restricting access to coop
control cube steal so the reason you
want to do this is because coop control
is a very powerful command-line tool if
any of you have used the g-cloud command
line tools or AWS command line tools
this is very similar but it's
specifically for kubernetes itself and
so obviously this lets you do things
like create update and delete resources
within kubernetes schedule pods pretty
much anything and so it's really
important to restrict you know not only
who can run this but where they can run
it from and so the way that you can do
that on GCE is through firewall rules
and enforcing kind of a bastion model
and so if anyone's not familiar that's
where you would have a dedicated VM or
choke point where you say the only way
to connect
with ssh into production is through that
one host and then you can create
firewall rules that restrict where you
can call the kubernetes api from to
adjust your Bastion host and so that's
what we're seeing here highlighted in
blue you see that we're restricting the
source tags to the SSH Bastion the
target tags to the Cabrini's controller
and you would just apply this through
the deployment manager in this case so I
just follow the blue things on the ammo
file indeed ok
for kubernetes engine we have a feature
called authorize networks authorize
networks lets you sir first of all when
you connect to the communities engine
master that connection is protected
using TLS and is authenticated and you
can further restrict the set of IP
addresses that can talk to the
community's master using authorized
networks authorized networks lets you
restrict up to 20 networks that you'd
like to connect to using HTTP Crimmins
engine it's sorry this feature is
currently in beta another feature that's
related to this is private clusters that
is also in beta private clusters gives
your nodes private RFC 1918 addresses to
to communicate with the master within to
use anyways and that it's effectively
implemented as an authorized network so
the nodes can talk directly as an
authorized network to your to your
master yeah next step is our back our
back is role based access control and
it's how you set individual permissions
on individual resources in kubernetes
so things like how you set permissions
to talk to use pods deployments
containers etc basically any resource
that you can think of you define the
roles based on your particular use cases
so you would say for example I need a
human user or a plug-in like my logging
plug-in to talk to a particular
component you'd give it a role by
binding the the user in green here to
the role in red and the set of
permissions to that particular role
there's also a couple of predefined
roles infirmities including things like
cluster admin for common use cases now
the recommendation that we have here is
that you disable a back start let me
taste back our back is relatively new in
criminai days our back was introduced in
1.6 and
implemented as the default starting in
1.8 the security recommendation that we
have here is that you disable another
system called a backer attribute based
access control and instead enable our
back with minimum permissions now if
you're already using a back on premises
and it works for you that's great
there's no problem there don't you don't
have to change anything
but we typically see with enterprise
customers is that they're using a role
based access control mechanism anyway
it's right it's easier to manage if
somebody quits my company tomorrow I can
just remove them from that rule rather
than having to change individual
permissions so if Jesse for some reason
decided to quit the company he
co-founded tomorrow they could just take
him off of that rule and he wouldn't
have access to customer data it's just
simpler to another another good use case
for using our bag here I can I think
about it is for compliance needs so if I
need to be able to say for example who
has access to customer data if I only
have one rule that has that access I can
just look at who has access to that rule
it's much easier for me to maintain that
so we have an example here of what a our
back definition looks like this is from
the kubernetes documentation and you can
see here highlighted in blue again that
it's the ammo file with blue indeed
we're giving the Blue Team user here
cluster admin rights in the blue
namespace and you can see that there so
in the metadata section you've got the
namespace subjects the user account and
of course down at the bottom there is
the admin role and on communities engine
it's also very similar so like it is
incriminate open source criminals engine
enables are back by default for clusters
created with 1.8 or higher that is if
you open your laptop right now and go to
a new tab and create a new cluster our
backs enable if you don't have to do
anything the recommendation for
communities engine is that you use I am
to manage permissions at the project
level for example using the crew naze
developer role for granting access to
your cluster and then using our back at
the cluster and namespace level to set
permissions on individual resources next
up we have using a network policy so as
we mentioned earlier the default for all
possible communication is open and so if
that scares you or if you have
reasons to isolate that traffic then you
can use a network policy to accomplish
that and so we have an example of what
that looks like one thing to point out
here with network policy because I often
that could ask this question is that
this is really about inter cluster
communication if you're thinking about
cluster to cluster communication or
service to service communication this
doesn't solve that problem you're gonna
want to do something like a service mesh
like this to you so more gamal here more
blue highlights so you can see here what
we're doing is we're restricting the
traffic from engine X such that the only
traffic allowed is that that's coming
from the ingress controller with a label
label of access equals true and so
anything that doesn't actually have that
label won't be able to talk to engine X
incriminate engine is very similar you
can set a network policy by using the
network policy API
I'd submitted using calico all you have
to do is pass a flag with an able
network policy flag and then you can set
a network policy as you as normal as you
would in Chrome at ease disabling the
kurenai's dashboard so some of you might
be familiar with this dashboard it's a a
UI that's part of the open source
version of Carini's that lets you do
things like manager cluster create a new
deployment monitor what's going on etc
how many of you actually use the renée's
dashboard guess maybe like 10% of people
that sounds about right typically if
you're using a cloud provider or you
prefer the command line keeps ETL then
you are probably not putting this
dashboard into your environment the the
reason that we mention it is that it's
been sort of part of some high profile
hacks it's made some cameo appearances
and in the public eye recently so
specifically in February of 2018 Tesla
was made the news for having Akron ace
console coming his dashboard that was
open on the public web this was sitting
on the public web not password protected
and had access to their cloud service
account credentials hackers found this
like probably on showdown or something
like that and stole the credentials
logged in and started mining
cryptocurrency that's not you know
particularly unusual so I think that
happens pretty off
Tesla's not the only one you know this
also happened to Weight Watchers and
Aviva in the last couple of couple
months
lazeric estimates that there are 20 over
20,000 open kubernetes dashboards on the
web of which 300 have no password
protection whatsoever so this is
actually a big deal so how do I protect
myself well you have three options you
can take the most secure and laziest
option a rare combo there of just not
deploying in the first place if you're
running your own cluster because this is
a separate yamo file another yamo file
another VM file and so you can just not
deploy it and then you'll be secure
option yeah lazy option that's pretty
great that's the option we take option
number two is that you could just keep
it deployed or you know choose to deploy
it but with reduced permissions
associated with at the service account
but obviously then you're probably going
to reduce the functionality of the
dashboard you won't be able to use it to
do as many things so that's a trade-off
there another option is that you can
just stick some authentication in front
of it maybe using a reverse proxy that
requires G suite authentication or
something like that
so that's your option number three on
consumption we followed option two and
then kind of went option one so starting
with criminals engine 1.7 or higher
we've removed permissions from that
dashboard doesn't haven't been accessed
by default in starting with commands
engine 110 and higher the dashboard is
just completely disabled we don't we
don't deploy it for you
if you're using commands engine you
probably can just use the cloud console
for anything you'd want to do anyways or
the command line that's what we
recommend and a quick note here though
obviously these are just for new cluster
creations so if you have an old cluster
that you've been updating for last year
please go in and disable that dashboard
right that's not disabled for you by
default so take care of that to make
sure you're not open so next up we've
got that famed infamous default service
account token so it's important to
understand what this is this is not GCP
service counts this is kubernetes
service counts so just to kind of
clarify that Before we jump in every
namespace gets its own default service
account it's used by the pod to a
certain identity to the API controller
and so if you don't specify a more
specific service account the default
behavior is that
every pod will have this default surface
account token it'll use it and the
permissions are fairly generous and so
the reason that standard is because if a
pod is compromised an attacker could you
know steal and use that token and to do
bad things to perform arbitrary
operations and so that's sort of what
we're dealing with here so the nice
thing is that it's disabled by default
now as of kubernetes 1.8 and higher but
if you do have a legacy cluster or if
you are just paranoid and you want to
make absolutely sure it's not enabled
you can define that in the ml by just
setting autumn mount surface account
token to false basically once our back
is enabled that token still exists but
it has no permissions I can't do
anything so if you turn on our back you
get this for free and that's kind of
what happens in criminals engine since
we turn on our back by defaults as a
reminder a back has disabled our back
has enabled by default for clusters
created since 1.8 that token doesn't
have any privileges and can't be abused
in your environment the last thing we'll
talk about is pod security policy and
you know various Linux security
constructs so some of these might be
familiar with a farmer is a Linux
security module or LSM so let's restrict
your programs actions things like file
reads rights and executions it basically
means that if somebody can't run
arbitrary commands and environment that
you might not want it to run seccomp
short for secure computing mode
basically filters the status this calls
that your application can run it puts
your application in a one-way secure
state or if it tries to do a set if it's
calls it's not allowed like it tries to
do something other than like sig return
or exit et cetera the process is
automatically killed and so it can't
execute in your environment there's a
pretty good default the docker SATCOM
default profile that limits about 150
Suns uncommon or potentially unsafe
syscalls in your environment and that's
a good place to get started if you're
not sure what to do in your in your
space so how this is implemented in
communities is actually very confusing
and so we wanted to spend some time on
this so people make sure other people
understand if you have these different
things you'd like amendment like a farm
or set comp etcetera you define a set of
these things that you'd like to
implement in the security context of
your pod specification
this is not a separate llamo file this
is an existing animal file that you have
so your existing pod specification
animal file you define the security
context for all the things we just
mentioned a firmer set comp run is
written on root a variety of other
things just by defining it in that pod
specification it'll be enforced that
container run time by the runtime that
you're using by docker by cryo by
whatever you happen to use so the other
option if you want to do this on more
than just one pod specification rather
than like a copy Payson that across all
your pod mo files you can enforce this
globally by using a pod security policy
how that works is it uses an admission
controller which is a concept in
kubernetes that kicks in after
authentication and authorization it's
sort of a third gate and it looks at
every pod entering the cluster and
decides whether it shall pass or not and
so basically if you want kind of a
global pod security policy you would
want to set it sorry security context
applied and enforce that runtime the way
you would do that is by using a pod
security policy and enabling its
associated admission controller which we
will cover the very critical step of how
to make sure that actually happens on
the next slide I believe and just to
clarify here the security context is
enforced at runtime so once the thing is
running environment the pod to keep all
policy is enforced at creation time so
when the pod is being created in your
cluster so that's why it's also extra
confusing I think to follow along so
yeah this is what I was alluding to it's
really critical that you actually enable
the admission controller plugin for pod
security policy because otherwise that
lovely definition that you created will
do nothing and the restricted policy is
a pretty good starting point do you want
to walk us through some of this stuff
yeah so basically if we go from top to
bottom here
oh yeah mo blue yeah mo you can see that
we're limiting the pods from running as
privileged on the first blue line there
the second we're preventing privilege
escalation the third we're requiring the
container to actually run without root
privileges and fourth were forbidding
the pod from being
run as the route group and it's a much
longer file than this we just zoomed in
on the parts that are most interesting
you can find it on the communities
github for commands engine you can
movement in much the same way you just
create a cluster with a pod security
policy bypassing a flag to enable pod
security policy I'm just a quick note on
both kubernetes and criminals engine if
you enable pod security policy you have
to pass it a policy otherwise it assumes
that the policy that you passed it is
the empty policy and you will have no
pods in your cluster because they none
of them will match the policy so what's
next so we've covered these six items so
quickly recap how we what we talked
through the first one restricting access
to cube control cube cuddle
scale by using a bastion host for nine
days or using authorize networks in gke
second using our back so role based
access control to define and permission
roles in their permissions so for that's
enabled by default since 1.8 if you're
running on gke we suggest use I am at
the project level and are back at the
cluster namespace level using a network
policy to control pod to pod traffic
pata pod traffic is open by default so
you can restrict that using a network
policy natively available in gke as well
protecting the community's dashboard
either disable it or restrict access to
it given that it uses a highly
privileged service account in criminales
it's not deployed by default so the lazy
option works pretty well and on
kubernetes engine it is has no
admittance 1.7 and is fully disabled
since 1:10 but if you've been upgrading
your cluster go disable that next
disable the service account token sorry
yeah the service account token by
enabling our back which gives that token
no actual permissions its default since
in communities in gke since 1.8 and
using a pod security policy to enable
things like the docker set comm profile
or other security restrictions using pod
security policy at the admission
controller and that's in beta in both
communities and GK
so we talked about some of these things
some of the things that are grayed out
here now are actually all the things
that GK does for you by default so you
don't have to worry about setting up any
of the things that are grayed out I also
want to point out that a lot of the
other thing
our one-line changes we were talking
about earlier using containers using
communities makes these things
relatively simple restricting access to
cue cuddle turn-on authorize networks
network policy pasa Network policy you
know setup odd security policy pass the
security net positive a policy it's
fairly straightforward for you to enable
some of these things and I also want to
highlight some of the areas that are a
little bit newer in this space newer
ideas and concepts that are coming to
discussion one of these here is
verifying that the binaries that you
that you create are deployed I'd sorry
that you've built are deployed there's a
couple of open-source projects here
kritis and griffiths that you might have
seen from google come out in december
around how we make sure that what what
is the point in to environment is
actually what you build what you've
signed scanning images for known
vulnerability so you can use a like a
partner solution there's a open source
solutions like claire and micro scanner
to make sure that you know what's
actually in the images before you deploy
them and then further down the line
sandboxing google open source g visor in
may there's a talk on g visor later this
week do check it out limiting the
identity that are used by pods there's a
new proposal around pod identity
incriminate it's open source so if
you're interested please do go check
that out check out the github you know
issue issue tracker and and tell us what
you think of that proposal and using a
service mesh for authentication and
encryption so sto there's lots of talks
at this conference on SEO and you saw
the announcements this morning so check
that out as well so we've been talking a
lot of about communities hardening and
gke hardening hopefully I'm starting to
convince Jesse and convince some of you
that gke makes a lot of that easier for
you so first off GK provides a lot of
the security best practices by default
you saw all the things I've already
grayed out we're definitely working on
on having more and more things built in
by default for you so you don't have to
manage those from the get-go there was
always going to be app level hardening
and fine tuning to do and protecting
that top layer your actual application
in the shared responsibility model is
still still your responsibility
next gke patches you to the latest
version automatically so criminals
engine manages a master for you and we
patch the master for you automatically
you can also turn on this feature called
node Auto upgrade and will patch your
nodes for you as well that's a super
cool security super power feature if
people don't realize like you'll just
get the security patches without you
having to do anything that was that's
why you guys went to containers in the
first place
right like you don't have to manage that
stuff so we'll take care of it for you
the last is that company's engine plugs
into a lot of the Google security
features that we already have that exist
elsewhere so if you're already familiar
with
I am cloud audit logging virtual private
clouds etc you can just use those things
with criminales engine you don't have to
worry about learning a new concept we
also have a ton of partners on gke and
on GCP in general including some around
containers specifically security
security specifically so that's
something you're interested in go check
them out go check out the booths that
are here at the conference today to
learn more about urbanised security and
communities engine hardening check out
the short links I'll just pause here for
a second while you take photos okay and
then if you want to learn more on
container security at this conference we
have a ton of talks so we're the first
upper right-hand up upper left-hand box
here but there's a talk later today on
sto and a bunch tomorrow and on Thursday
to learn more about container security
[Music]